good morning Hank it's Thursday August
3rd it's Esther day and I love you
yesterday is a holiday founded by Esther
Earl our friend and a long time
nerdfighter who died of cancer in 2010
when she was 16. and she wanted
yesterday her holiday to be about the
other kinds of love the love that we
don't celebrate on Valentine's Day love
between family and friends and
especially taking the time to say I love
you when it's hard to say it now I don't
want to flatter myself and say that I
was in any way involved with the
creation of yesterday but I do suspect
that part of what Esther was thinking
was my gosh it's hard for these two
nerds to say I love you to each other
and so I'm gonna start a holiday where
they have to do it at least once a year
but it has been hard over the years like
I'm about to confess something super big
brothery and embarrassing but sometimes
when we were like just out of college or
you were still in college and we would
have like our occasional once a year or
once every six month phone call we don't
have these great phone calls we talk for
like 45 minutes we'd have like broad
ranging conversations about all kinds of
things and then when it came time to
hang up I would want to say I love you
and I wouldn't and then I would just be
like all right well take care and then
you'd hang up and then and then after we
hung up I I would say I love you but now
I'm functionally forced to say it to you
once a year and actually we have been
saying I love you more in private
haven't we Hank because this year's
yesterday uh there's no two ways about
it it's different your cancer diagnosis
has reminded us that life is fragile and
also that we are very fortunate to be in
life with the people we're in it with
it's also helped me to remember the cost
of not saying I love you I need the
people in my life to know that I love
them and I need to know that I am loved
Esther saw that at 16 better than I did
in 2010 and so she gave us the gift of
this holiday and this opportunity to
tell the people in our lives we care
about that we care about them but I
don't just love you Hank I also really
deeply admire you there's a lot of gifts
that have been given to me in my life
but very few of them stack up with the
one that I received on May 5th 1980
I'm gonna I'm gonna try a different way
look I've always known that Cancer Sucks
our dad had cancer twice when we were
little it had a huge impact on his life
on our lives uh I I've seen cancer up
close in in friends and and in the lives
of of people like Esther and her family
uh so I I didn't need you to get cancer
to know that Cancer Sucks uh but I have
I have been reminded Anew how difficult
it is for the person living with cancer
for the people supporting them when our
structures our societal structures are
not set up to support patients and their
families effectively and after Esther
died her family set up a charity called
this star won't go out that provides
direct financial support to families of
kids living with cancer and I understand
better than ever just how much
difference supporting this star won't go
out can make in the lives of those
families because like Hank we don't need
money that's not a source of stress it
wasn't a big deal for you you to be able
to leave your job on a moment's notice
for an indefinite period of time but for
the vast majority of people all of that
and so much more isn't easy this star
won't go out provides such an essential
service for families like that so in
addition to encouraging you to say I
love you to the people in your life you
love especially when it's hard I
encourage you to check out this star
won't go out and donate if you can
tswgo.org link in the doobly-doo also
Hank this summer has sucked and I have
this intense need to add but to the end
of every negative sentence like this
summer has sucked but I've gotten closer
to my brother that's true but but there
are better ways where we could have
gotten closer you know or this summer
has sucked but I learned a lot which is
also true you do learn a lot when you
get promoted from unpaid social media
intern to Temporary and reluctant CEO
I would have rather learned those
lessons in a different way though but
here's a but I can feel good about nope
here's a butt I can get behind
definitely not
um all right here's a butt that works
for me no frick I'm just gonna say it
instead of introing it this summer has
sucked massively but I have seen up
close how much love matters how much the
love of your colleagues at dftba and
complexly matters how much the love of
your spouse and your kid matters how
much the love of your family and your
friends matter what we really need in
this world and all in the end we can
really give each other is accompaniment
and attention to walk with each other
and to listen to each other so that none
of us has to go through everything that
we will have to go through alone and so
I've been reminded just how much all
those kinds of Love matter and how wise
Esther was at the age of 16 to start of
all holidays this one Hank I love you so
much happy yesterday I will see you
tomorrow